[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyst host of the Ross Tucker football
podcast the former NFL offensive lineman
joining us on the program
Ross it's good to see you there was a
play last night with Mac Jones when he
was sliding
and he got to the ground and then he
lifted his leg up his foot up right into
the groin area of one of the Chicago
Bears defensive backs uh brisker hit him
in the brisket and I was wondering did
that feel intentional to you
oh that's a good question uh yes I did
see that by the way that should be an
automatic penalty right I mean there's
no reason for the quarterback's foot to
be that high I understand maybe
protecting yourself a little bit but
doesn't even that high that it gets to
the nether regions of a jumping
defensive pack like Jaquan brisker I
don't know that he intentionally tried
to hit him where nobody should ever hit
anyone ever but
um he definitely had the foot up on
purpose Dan I mean he definitely was
foot up to I think protect himself and
not have the guy come at him I don't
know if he was really trying to kick him
in the nads or not
do you think Belichick had a plan to
start or play both quarterbacks last
night
well I think I believe you told them
that
and I believe you know because shefter
even reported it like right before kick
Well he kind of hedged it a little bit
he said I could see it now I don't know
if that's code for I'm being told but I
can't say I'm being told this
yeah I mean the reality is Dan if Mac
Jones was playing great I don't think
they're pulling him unless they have
such a big lead that they can put zappy
in so that sounds great to say we're
going to play them both
but I don't think he really would have
done that if Mac Jones came out and was
lighting the world on fire they had two
three and outs and a terrible
interception by Mac Jones that's why
they made the Swap and remember
Belichick told Lisa Salters at halftime
that they were both going to play in the
second half and then it was just zappy
the whole second half
yeah I'm trying to figure out what he
who starts against the Jets
probably Mac Jones who would you start
well that's a good question I would
still start Mac Jones you know if you
start zappy
boy when do you go back to Mac Jones
only if zappy falters at that point I
mean it's really interesting to me how
quickly we forget what Mac Jones did
last year I mean he was thought of as
far and away as being the best of the
rookie quarterbacks he led the patriots
to the playoffs double-digit wins after
the disaster that was the 2020 season
with Cam Newton yeah it's it's
unbelievable how fast we all forget that
Patriots fans I mean Patriots fans Dan
right from the start were chanting for
zappy I will say this though
unlike any other coach I played for Dan
Belichick likes this
you know like other places I was they
would want you to be comfortable they
they wouldn't want the quarterbacks
looking over their shoulder Belichick
doesn't look at it that way a Belichick
likes when guys are on edge Belichick
likes when guys think that their jobs
are in Jeopardy he wants you to have he
wants that tension he believes that that
makes everybody work harder prepare
harder cream of the crap right whatever
you want to call it right he thinks that
that's healthy he likes I I really
believe he likes that both these guys
are on edge now about their job okay but
at that position I don't want my
quarterback on edge or my quarterbacks
on edge I need you to be worried about
the Jets you know if I want to play
games with a defensive lineman or a
defensive back okay I can do that to
Malcolm Butler I can't do that to my
quarterback especially young
quarterbacks who probably are going in
you know lacking the confidence that you
want or that you need at that position
but Belichick's done this before he did
it with Bledsoe and Brady he did it with
Ty Law and lawyer Malloy Richard C more
Cam Newton you know he brought him last
year and then all of a sudden it's like
uh you're not our starter Mac Jones is I
get it but I think it's a little
dangerous when you're trying to figure
out who is your quarterback right now
I totally agree with you I saw where
Peyton and Eli said that last night as
well it's tough to play quarterback that
way plus that position is also no matter
how old you are or no matter how much
experience you have it's still a
leadership position and it's tough to
have guys at that position looking over
their shoulder I'd be curious to hear
what he says I know for a fact that he
likes when the guys at other positions
are on edge feeling insecure he believes
that that's how you get the most out of
them I think it seems like he feels that
way about quarterback too the way he's
handling it talking to Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst the former
NFL offensive lineman host of even money
a betting podcast and you can check him
out on social media at rosstucker NFL
there was footage of two officials
asking Mike Evans for an autograph in
the tunnel
and they were working the Buccaneers
game
big deal little deal no deal
ironically Dan
I called the ULM army game on Saturday
and some member of the media from ULM
had three of my football cards and asked
me to sign them first time in and since
2008. I've been doing this since 2008
first time anybody in a Press Box ever
asked for my autograph first time like
that was that was you're not supposed to
do that I was happy to do it I was happy
that anybody had my cards and my woman
in my office
I was thrilled I showed everybody in the
booth there I was like look look I got
cards and this guy out there he wants me
to sign them I'll do it for him you know
but no in all sincerity way to make it
about you Ross I'm trying to find out
does this happen very often is this a
big deal little deal no deal that two
officials asked Mike Evans for an
autograph yeah I think it's probably
a medium deal I'm not taking any of your
three options I'm gonna go between
little deal and big deal it's not a
little deal well one of the officials
has been doing this for 21 years he's
been an NFL official for 21 years
I'd love to see his memorabilia room if
he's been doing it for 21 years
um over here I got Tom Brady uh oh
that's Eli Man uh Ben Roethlisberger
over here how often does this happen do
you think
I've never heard of it before okay I've
never now maybe they just weren't asking
me but but I I've never heard of it
before I think it's a bad look Dan
because a player is doing you a favor
it's a horrible look Ross yeah it's
horrible yeah
we have video it's video is that's where
things change when somebody goes uh do
you have it on tape uh yeah we do oh
okay that changes everything I think I
think they might get fired I really do I
mean I think I think there's a decent
chance of that because you can't have
any thought in your mind when a call is
being made of have any affinity for any
player because they did a favor for you
you just can't have that there's too
many judgment calls that can't be I
don't care if it's conscious or
subconscious Dan that can't be in your
brain somewhere when Mike Evans is
downfield and it's questionable whether
it's past interference or not I mean
what does Mike Evans say the next game
that guy is the ref he doesn't get a
call hey man I gave you the autograph
last week for your nephew and you didn't
give me the call like it's it's terrible
the only thing I want to know how it
went down too like at what point did he
ask him for it you know like what point
was there hey Mike I got you on the next
illegal contact penalty can I get an
autograph out of the game I mean it's
it's bad it's a medium I'm not gonna go
big deal but it's a medium yeah but if
you think they could get fired then it's
a big D feel there's only one way out we
got it for a sick kid
that's it that's the only way that you
can go all right I guess
I like Dan that you're already thinking
ahead to plausible excuses to try to get
out of it I didn't know you had that in
you I did this growing up it's like I'm
I'm in trouble how do I get out of
trouble what is my story that's it I'm
gonna stick with that
uh you know what
um I what the reason why I said it's not
a big deal is because I don't think it
affected the game right they they lost
21-3 I don't think it affected a big
deal to me would be like if it affected
the outcome of the game or there were
bad calls that were made that's why I'm
going medium deal with it right now all
right
trying to figure this out with the
Buccaneers and the Packers you got
Buccaneers they're going to be playing
on Thursday night against the Ravens
I I don't know
kind of calms this all down I I guess if
the Buccaneers win Thursday that
certainly helps I got the Packers
playing your Buffalo Bills on Sunday
this this could get worse before it gets
better if it does get better which team
has a better chance of making it better
sooner
I'll I'll still say the Bucks because
the Packers first of all bhaktiari not
playing on Sunday Dan huge red flag I
don't know if we'll ever see him again
huge red flag they said that there are
days that he wakes up that his knee just
doesn't feel right if he talked to me I
would tell him to strongly consider
never playing again because that's the
only me he has oh he's got two but you
know what I'm saying
um and and they moved around the whole
offensive line which isn't good
and the receivers how much better are
they going to get at least in Tampa I
know what Godwin is I know what Mike
Evans is the offensive line might get
better as they get a little bit more
time together I think they're better
defensively but honestly I think it's a
bad look for both teams I think they're
both where they deserve to be and I
think the quarterbacks deserve blame you
know it it bothers me both of them
bother me dad I mean number one Aaron
Rodgers is saying we just need to
simplify things a little bit in October
well maybe if you were at OTAs in May
and didn't miss out on the 15 practice
option the 10 OTAs and the mini camp and
we're working with the rookies and the
new receivers maybe you would have
figured that out months ago instead
Aaron Roger they lose the game he's like
maybe this was the best thing for us I
mean he's like you know he's totally
changed he he look he's like he's like
the dude from Dazed and Confused now on
in that movie it's been a while for
Brady
you know Dan this is this is sad for me
with Brady because I played with him
parts of o5 and 06 ton of respect for
him he if he would have just stayed
retired it would have been like like the
perfect career yeah and this year
with the off the field stuff missing
training camp for 10 days you know
yelling the way they're playing I mean
look he's still Tom Brady but it's just
taking a little bit of the Shine off of
what was almost like the perfect career
the good news for him and both of them
that they have 10 games I mean there's a
lot of football left and by the way
especially for Brady Dan their division
stinks I mean they're still gonna win
the NFC South so all that really matters
for Brady is that they're playing well
enough in late December and January is
that when they win the NFC south at like
nine and eight or whatever it is there
they can maybe go on a playoff run Brady
ever yell at you
no I wasn't I I wasn't there enough for
him to yell at me to be honest with you
I didn't play enough the only thing he
ever said to me really was in the Huddle
when I was at Center like in the
training camp or in OTAs
I I think I told us before Dan never
play with anybody oh he did yell at me
he did yell at me I told you about this
so on the field the only thing he ever
said to me was like all right Ross me
and you great snap first great this is
like in May the one time he yelled at me
was when it was the Friday night that
Talladega Nights came out during
training camp we had the next two days
off because Belichick went to the Hall
of Fame to see Harry Carson inducted
so before we went to Talladega Nights we
ate at this barbecue joint right near
Gillette Stadium and when I went to go
pay my tab
he came over like the psychopath that he
is and I mean that as a compliment it
was like Ross I got it I got it I'm like
Tom it's like 13 I'll pay for he's like
no I got it I'm paying I was like okay
so that was the one time Tom Brady
yelled at me
and you've never recovered from that
where he was going to pick up your check
you know what you know what I think I
told this before but real quick when
they signed me the year before we all
went out one night and the guys were
asking me about Buffalo
and I was telling them how generous
Bledsoe was Bledsoe would always pay the
tab bledsoe's Christmas gifts were
amazing Brady was like further down the
table but you ever like look at someone
and you know they're not looking down
but you kind of think they're listening
in my head and maybe I'm making this up
in my head Brady remembered what I said
about Bledsoe and when we went out that
one night he was determined that Bledsoe
was not going to have a one-up on him
and he was going to pay my 13 tab for
the ribs or whatever I had at that
barbecue joint I I you'll never convince
me otherwise might not be true but
that's my story I'm sticking with it but
you went out with the beer drinking
Brady before same night before he
started you know the health kick with
you know kale and all the avocado ice
cream you you went out with Brady when
he was drinking beer all three of those
things happen on the same night it was
Brady against three rookie o Lyman he
crushed them crushed the cup slammed it
like a Gronk Spike like as intense
anybody I've ever seen then we're about
to leave to go to the movie and he pays
my barbecue Bill tab then we go to the
movie theater Dan it was opening night
of your boy Will Ferrell's Talladega
Nights I think the movie started at nine
we got there like at 9 20.
they didn't start the movie they waited
for us because Matt Light had called
ahead of him we had three rows totally
blocked off but I think they might have
kept selling the tickets because they
didn't know the roads are black so there
are people like standing people like
standing in the back of the movie
theater we come rolling in that was
after the Patriots have won like three
Super Bowls in four years we sit down
Brady and Castle are right in front of
me right in front of me and the people
right in front of them it's pitch dark
they're
I think I think it's Brady like getting
that close like I think it's great and
he didn't move he just had his hat down
like this didn't move and then the movie
started and they like escorted him out
that was like my one of two nights I did
anything maybe three nights anything
social with Brady and I got three
awesome stories out of it good to talk
to you as always have a great weekend
thank you buddy all right I always
appreciate Ross Tucker he's always got a
story always he did yell at me yeah